Xavier Breton interpellé la ministre de
la Culture et expliquer avoir été choqué
par les menaces à l'encontre de C8 et
cnews bravo bravo Monsieur breton
regardez
madame la ministre de très nombreuses
personnes ont été choquées par les
menaces que vous avez formulées à
l'encontre des chaînes C8 et c'est news
en menaçant ces chaînes de ne pas
renouveler leur fréquence vous avez bien
sûr heurter les téléspectateurs qui
trouvent une autre manière de s'informer
mais vous avez aussi choqué tous ceux
qui sont attachés au pluralisme de
l'information mais là vous avez
scandalisé tous ceux qui défendent cette
grande liberté constitutionnelle qui est
la liberté d'expression dans une
démocratie sur un sujet aussi sensible
que l'information un gouvernement se
doit d'observer une stricte réserve en
aucun cas il ne peut prendre parti et
c'est pourtant ce que vous avez fait et
en le faisant non seulement vous avez
menacé la liberté d'expression mais vous
avez aussi remis en cause l'indépendance
de l'arcome l'autorité de régulation de
la communication audiovisuelle et
numérique normalement l'arc devrait être
une autorité publique indépendante mais
par vos propos madame la ministre vous
discréditer et son indépendance et son
impartialité alors madame la ministre de
la Culture allez-vous observer à
l'avenir une stricte neutralité pour
respecter la liberté d'expression et le
pluralisme de l'information
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
après-midi aussi il y a un autre
sénateur Roger carochi
il s'en est prêt à son tour à la
ministre on lui demandant de laisser
l'arcom faire son travail ah non elle
s'est pas fait que des amis
l'agrément aux chaînes en question vous
interférez avec les décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'art
comme pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à
partir de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de l'arcom alors madame
la ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez-la comme faire son travail
[Applaudissements]
sur la réforme des retraites et
honnêtement depuis le début c'est le
dawa c'est le small c'est le total ça
envoie des punchlines à tout va sa
gueule ça se coupe la parole ça se prend
la tête on a deux doigts de se croire
ici
regardez on a fait une petite compile ça
s'appelle la Dark assemblée
au programme cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était la réforme des
retraites et c'était un bordel mon vieux
et mais pas encore tôt donc si on
pouvait avancer dans un silence relatif
et vous êtes à lomusé de ce que nous
pouvons
vous essayez de mettre
le sur d'autres groupes politiques
c'était tellement le bordel que certains
étant roue libre dans l'hémicycle la
parole est à monsieur Sylvain Maillard
pour le groupe Renaissance
et le calme et à peine revenu qu'un
député a décidé de remettre une pièce
dans la machine on a retrouvé un peu de
calme dans cette émission et la droite
et l'extrême droite sont repartis à la
buvette et forcément à force de gueuler
bah ça picote la gorge de la Commission
et de la séance
et les députés aussi ont des auteurs il
s'appelle Stéphane Bern et punchline
Mama elle n'existe pas donc deux grasses
plutôt que d'invectiver et de sortir des
sotises va servir peu ouprou et on a des
nouvelles Daniel panier rue hachée
qui s'en sont pris plein la tronche les
micros aussi
s'il vous plaît monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
allez Agnès je te laisse le mot de la
fin c'est horrible
[Rires]
je suis désolé
ment Agnès
une fois alors c'est un tel bordel dans
l'hémicycle que la présidente de
l'Assemblée était au bout de sa vie on
aurait dit une preuve de 5e B regardez
son écran des recettes c'est l'école
regarde madame la Présidente
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas attrapé les pupilles la
parole est au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre on va suspendre 5
minutes le temps que c'est ta collègue
laisse le gouvernement s'exprimer
alors c'est pas fini juste après Soumia
chanter dans l'hémicycle et là c'était
le coup de théâtre pour la présidente
elle était à deux doigts d'envoyer tout
le monde chez la CPE
s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues
non non vous vous croyez où
[Musique]
non mais c'est incroyable non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre attitude est inacceptable donc on
passe maintenant
aux amendements après l'article 2 et
nous avons des amendements pouvaient
être soumis à une discussion commune des
amendements
[Musique]
alors d'ailleurs il y a un député les
filles François pickman qui a voulu
faire jeune et cité du Jul et du sch
problème c'est qu'ils soient pas du tout
en fait il était ridicule regardez moi
je vous invite à écouter par exemple un
rappeur comme sch qui décrit souvent les
conditions pénibles qu'a vécu son père
au travail et qui a cette phrase qui ici
prend un petit peu tout son sens il dit
se lever pour 1200 euros c'est un
descente
je vais pour 1000 dossiers insultes se
lever pour 1200 euros c'est un descente
Jul qui dit personne ne veut soulever
des palettes tout le monde veut sa
retraite tout le monde veut s'appelait
personne ne peut soulever personne ne
veut soulever des palettes tout le monde
veut sa retraite
[Musique]
faut qu'il arrête faut qu'ils arrêtent
ça vient de tomber je vous jure que
c'est vrai les députés viennent d'être
suspendus pour une raison totalement
improbable mais j'ai l'impression que ça
se lâche dans l'assemblée regardez
regardez c'est vrai c'est pas une blague
figurez-vous que les députés y débattent
et c'est plutôt rare depuis le début de
cette réforme des retraites mais alors
au moment où je descends pour pouvoir
être avec vous en direct ou je quitte
l'hémicycle patatras suspension de
séance non pas pour un incident entre
députés cette fois-ci mais parce qu'il y
a une odeur bizarre voilà ce que m'ont
dit des députés en quittant l'hémicycle
je n'ai pas de précision sur l'odeur
particulière en tout cas tous les
députés ont été appelés à sortir il y a
maintenant deux trois minutes bien sûr
on vous tiendrons au courant dès que
nous aurons plus d'informations là
dessus pour vous dire que décidément on
y arrive pas
voilà les chéris apparemment Jean-Marie
Bigard est passé par l'Assemblée